[Applause]
or maybe feed figuring some things out
three to shoot Murray the spin
[Applause]
unbelievable Telly and spirit right here
great move a little spin gets Alexander
Walker off balancing it afterwards he
points at him as he's going down the
floor Denver is out of fouls Edwards
gets a Town's pick here he comes off
balance hangs bangs it in
my goodness and this right here is
special attacking off balance double
clutch off the glass Anthony Edwards
stepping up the 2023 NBA playoffs are
presented by Google pixel
Anderson calling for the screen gets it
caught a shoot Edwards left open he
buries it massive shot for Edwards so
they give it to jokic as his third
personal
Edwards as we cross the seven minute
Mark spinning hanging puts it in
Edwards takes his time backs down the
smaller Defender and this right here a
contested Fade Away we know someone we
watched a few decades ago we'll get a
steady diet a two-man game Murray and
jokic
Minnesota is out of fouls this is Murray
scores
defensive end and obviously on this side
a lot of Jamal Murray
hanging couple Murray is back it's
official
finally lead this Denver team on a deep
postseason run
Edwards
[Applause]
six-point game as we move inside of two
minutes left
Murray looking for some daylight steps
back fires
bringing the ball down to court
Edwards against jokic elevates contested
deep in the corner that's a long two